we're told that a standard deck of 52
playing cards includes 4 aces
4 kings and 44 other cards suppose that
luis
randomly draws four cards without
replacement
what is the probability that luis gets
two aces
and two kings in any order
so like always pause this video and see
if you can work through this
all right now to figure out this
probability we can think about this is
going to be the
number of let's call them draws
with exactly two aces and two kings
two aces and
two kings and that's going to be over
the total
number of possible draws of four cards
so number of possible
draws of
four cards now for many of y'all this
bottom the denominator here might be a
little bit easier to think about
we know that there's 52 total cards of
which we are choosing
for so we could say 52 choose 4 and that
will tell us
the total number of possible draws of
four cards
how many combinations of four cards can
we get when we're picking from 52
but the top here might be a little bit
more of a stumper
we can think we have exactly two spots
for aces
so we're choosing two aces out of how
many possible aces
well there's four total aces so if we
say four
choose two this is the total number of
ways
when you don't care about order that you
can have two out of your four
aces picked and then separately we can
use similar logic to say all right
there's also four choose two
ways of picking two kings out of four
possible kings
and now the total number of draws with
two aces and
two kings this is going to be the
product of these two
and if you're wondering why you can just
multiply it think about it
for every scenario that you have these
two aces
you have four choose two scenarios of
which kings you're dealing with so you
would take the product of them
and we've already done many examples of
computing combinatorics like this so i
will leave you there if you're so
motivated i encourage you to be
you can actually calculate this value